HURRICANE MARIA.
TONIGHT WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
THE RECOVERY OR LACK OF IT
THERE.
CORRESPONDENT BRYAN LLENAS IS AN
OLD SAN JUAN WITH THE STORY.
>> WE ARE TREATED AS
SECOND-CLASS CITIZENS.
>> PUERTO RICO GOVERNOR IS
FRUSTRATED.
HE SAID THE HURRICANE MARIA
DISASTER FUNDS ARE TAKING TOO
LONG TO ARRIVE AND HE BLAMES
CONGRESS.
>> WHY IS THE SAME COP PROCESS
IN FLORIDA OR TEXAS, IT TAKES A
WEEK, AND PUERTO RICO, IT TAKES
MONTHS.
>> HE IS NOT ALONE.
ON TUESDAY, NEARLY TWO DOZEN
PUERTO RICAN ACTIVISTS WERE
ARRESTED IN THE U.S. CAPITAL
DEMANDING CONGRESS PROVIDE MORE
FINANCIAL AID TO THE
COMMONWEALTH.
PUERTO RICO CLAIMS THAT NEEDS
$94 BILLION IN AID.
CONGRESS APPROPRIATED
23 BILLION, LESS THAN 2 BILLION
HAS BEEN SENT.
>> I WANT TO SEE SHOVELS IN THE
GROUND AND THINGS BEING BUILT.
HOUSES BEING BUILT TO CODE.
I WANT TO SEE A POWER SYSTEM
THAT'S UNDER CONSTRUCTION THAT
WILL WITHSTAND A STORM.
>> MICA SAYS FEMA'S EFFORTS HAS
BEEN UNLIKE ANY HURRICANE
RESPONSE HE HAS SEEN, SPENDING
MORE THAN $6 BILLION SO FAR.
$15 MILLION HAS GONE TO SAN
SEBASTIAN, WHERE THE MAYOR
BLAMES SAN JUAN, NOT THE FEDS.
>> THIS TOWN TOOK CONTROL OF OUR
CIRCUMSTANCES AND RELISTED
OURSELVES UP.
>> FRUSTRATED AFTER NOT SEEING
POWER RESTORED IN A MONTH, THE
TOWN CREATED VOLUNTEER BRIGADES,
INCLUDING RETIRED LINEMAN TO
RESTORE POWER AND CLEAR DEBRIS
ON THEIR OWN.
HE SAYS THE PROBLEM IS IN FEMA
FUNDING.
>> THE GOVERNOR SHOULD HAVE
ACTED WITH MORE URGENCY.
HE SHOULD HAVE TAKEN CHARGE OF
THE UTILITY COMPANY.
IMMEDIATELY FIRING THOSE WHO
WEREN'T DOING THEIR JOBS.
>> ON TUESDAY THE GOVERNOR
APPOINTED A NEW HEAD OF THE
BANKRUPT GOVERNMENT ON POWER
UTILITY WIDELY BLAMED FOR THE
ISLANDS FEELING ELECTRIC
INFRASTRUCTURE.
5,000 BUSINESSES ARE NOW CLOSED
AND EXPECTING TO NEVER REOPEN.
JOHNNY RAMOS, PRESIDENT OF A
MANUFACTURING COMPANY, SAYS TIME
IS RUNNING OUT.
>> I CANNOT SIT DOWN AND WAIT
FOR THE GOVERNMENT.
I HAVE TO MOVE.
>> COMPOUNDING THE CRISES,
PUERTO RICO IS BANKRUPT.
TOMORROW TREASURY SECRETARY
STEVE MNUCHIN WILL BE TO THE
GOVERNOR HERE IN OLD SAN JUAN TO
SECURE THE TERMS FOR A
$2 BILLION DEAL.
HE SAYS HE WANTS TO ENTER